tensorflow patri systems they weren't
actually designed for llm so like that
was not that was not a thing and so what
where tensile actually has amazing power
in terms of scale and deployment and
things like that and I think Google is
I mean maybe not unmatched but they're
like incredible in terms of their
capabilities and gigantic scale
um many researchers using pytorch right
and so pytorch doesn't have those same
capabilities and so what modular can do
is it can help with that now if you take
a step back and say like what is modular
doing right so modular has like a
a bitter enemy they were fighting
against in the industry and it's one of
these things where everybody knows it
but nobody is usually willing to talk
about it the bitter enemy The Bitter
thing that we have to destroy that we're
all struggling with and it's like all
around it's like fish can't see water
it's complexity sure yes it's complexity
right that was very philosophical
and so if you look at it yes it is on
the hardware side yes all these all
these accelerators all these software
Stacks that go with the accelerator all
these like this massive complexity over
there you look at
what's happening on the modeling side
massive amount of complexity like things
are changing all the time people are
inventing turns out the research is not
done right and so people want to be able
to move fast Transformers are amazing
but there's a ton of diversity even
within Transformers and what's the next
Transformer right and you look into
serving also huge amounts of complexity
it turns out that all the cloud
providers right have all their very
weird but very cool hardware for
networking all this kind of stuff and
it's all very complicated people aren't
using that you look at classical serving
right there there's this whole world of
people who know how to write high
performance servers with zero copy
networking and like all all this fancy
uh asynchronous I O and like all these
fancy things and the in in the serving
Community very little that has pervaded
into the machine learning world right
and why is that well it's because again
these systems have been built up over
many years they they haven't been
rethought there hasn't been a first
principle's approach to this and so what
modular is doing is we're saying okay
we've built many of these things like so
I've worked on tensorflow and tpus and
things like that other folks on our team
like are worked on pytorch core we've
worked on onyx one time we've worked on
many of these other systems and so the
systems like the Apple accelerators and
all that kind of stuff like our team is
quite amazing and so one of the things
that roughly everybody modular is grumpy
about is that when you're working on one
of these projects you have a first order
goal
get the hardware to work get the system
to enable one more model get this
product out the door enable the specific
workload or make it solve this problem
for this this product team right and
nobody's been given a chance to actually
do that step back and so we as an
industry we didn't take two steps
forward we took like 18 steps forward in
terms of all this really cool technology
across compilers and systems and
runtimes and heterogeneous Computing
like all this kind of stuff and like all
this technology has been
you know I wouldn't say uh beautifully
designed but it's been proven in
different quadrants like you know you
look at Google with tpus massive huge
exaflops of compute strapped together
into machines that researchers are
programming in Python in a notebook
that's huge that's amazing it's
incredible right it's incredible and so
you look at the technology that goes
into that and the the algorithms are
actually quite General
and so lots of other Hardware out there
and lots of other teams out there don't
have the sophistication or that maybe
the the years working on it or the the
budget or whatever that Google does
right and so they should be getting
access to same algorithms but they just
don't have that right that's what
modular is doing is we're saying
cool this is not research anymore like
we've we've built Auto tuning in many
systems we've built programming
languages right and so like have have
you know implemented C plus plus I've
implemented Swift I've implemented many
of these things and so you know this
it's hard but it's not research and you
look at accelerators well we know
there's a bunch of different weird kind
of accelerators but they actually
cluster together
right and you look at gpus well there's
a couple of major vendors of gpus and
they maybe don't always get along but
their architectures are very similar you
look at CPUs CPUs are still super
important for the deployment side of
things you see new new architectures
coming out from all the cloud providers
and things like this and they're all
super important to the world right but
they don't have the 30 years of
development that the entrenched people
do right and so what modular can do is
we're saying okay all this complexity
like it's not it's not bad complexity
it's actually Innovation right and so
it's Innovation that's happening and
it's for good reasons but I have
sympathy for the poor software people
right I mean again I'm a generally a
software person too I love Hardware but
software people want to build
applications and products and solutions
that scale over many years
they don't want to build a solution for
one generation of Hardware with one
vendor's tools right and because of this
they need something that scales with
them they need something works on cloud
and mobile
right because you know their product
manager said hey I wanted to be have
lower latency and it's better for
personalization or whatever they decide
right products evolve and so the
challenge with the machine learning
technology and the infrastructure we
have today in the industry is that it's
all these Point Solutions
and because there are all these Point
Solutions it means that Azure product
evolves you have to like switch to
different technology Stacks or switch to
different vendor and what that does is
that slows down progress
so basically a lot of the things we've
developed in those little uh silos for
machine learning tasks you want to make
that the first class citizen of a
general purpose programming language
they can then be compiled across all
these kinds of Hardware well so it's not
really about a programming language I
mean the programming language is a
component of the mission right and the
mission is are not literal but our
joking mission is to save the world from
terrible AI software excellent okay
so so you know if you look at this
Mission you need a syntax so that's you
so yeah she needed programming language
right and and like we wouldn't have to
build the programming language if one
existed right so if python was already
good enough then cool we've just used it
right we're not just doing very large
scale expensive engineering projects for
the sake of it like it's to solve a
problem right it's also about
um uh accelerators it's also about
exotic numerics and B float 16 and
Matrix multiplications and convolutions
and like this this kind of stuff
um within the stack there are things
like uh kernel Fusion
that's a esoteric but really important
thing that leads to much better
performance and much more general
research hackability together
right and that that's enabled by the
Asics that's enabled by certain Hardware
so it's like where's the dance between
uh I mean several questions here like
how do you add a piece of Hardware to
this deck yeah if a new piece like if I
have this genius invention
of a specialized accelerator yeah how do
I add that to the module framework and
also how does modular as a standard
start to define the kind of
Hardware that should be developed yeah
so let me take a step back and talk
about status quo okay yes and so um if
you go back to tensorflow one Pi torch
one the this kind of time frame
um and these have all evolved and gotten
way more complicated so let's go back to
the the Glorious simple days right these
things basically were CPUs and Cuda and
so what you do is you say go do
a dense layer and a dens layer has a
matrix multiplication in it right and so
when you say that you say go do this big
operation of matrix multiplication and
if it's on a GPU kick off a Cuda kernel
if it's on CPU go do
like an Intel algorithm or something
like that with the Intel mko okay now
that's really cool if you're either in
video or Intel right but then more
Hardware comes in
right and and on one access you have
more Hardware coming in on the other
hand you have an explosion of innovation
in Ai and so what happened with both
tensorflow and pytorch is that the
explosion of innovation in AI has led to
it's not just about multiplication and
convolution these things have now like 2
000 different operators
and on the other hand you have I don't
know how many pieces of Hardware there
are out there it's a lot
it's it's not it's not even hundreds
it's probably thousands okay and across
all of Edge and across like all the
different things that are used at scale
yeah exactly I mean also it's not just
like hey guys everywhere yeah it's not a
handful of TPU Alternatives correct it's
it's every phone often with many
different right chips inside of it from
different vendors right like it's AI is
everywhere it's a thing right why are
they all making their own chips like
what why is everybody making their own
thing
well so is that a good thing official so
Chris's velocity on Hardware yeah right
so My Philosophy is that there isn't one
right solution
right and so I think that again we're at
the end of Moore's Law specialization
happens yeah if you if you're building
if you're training gpt5
you want some crazy super computer data
center thingy if you're making a smart
camera that runs on batteries you want
something that looks very different
if you're building a phone you want
something looks very different if you
have something like a laptop you want
something that looks maybe similar but a
different scale right and so AI ends up
touching all of our Lives robotics right
and like lots of different things and so
as you look into this these have
different Power envelopes there's
different trade-offs in terms of the
algorithms there's new Innovations and
sparsity and other data formats and
things like that and so uh Hardware
Innovation I think is a really good
thing right and what I'm interested in
is unlocking that Innovation there's
also like analog and Quantum and like
all the the
the really weird stuff right and so if
somebody can come up with a chip that
uses analog Computing and it's 100x more
power efficient think what that would
mean in terms of the daily impact on the
products we use that would be huge now
if you're building an analog computer
you may not be a compiler specialist
right these are different skill sets
right and so you can hire some compiler
people if you're running a big company
maybe but it turns out these are really
uh like exotic new generation of
compilers like this this is a different
thing right and so if you if you take a
step back out and come back to what is
the status quo status quo is that
if you're Intel or you're in video you
can you keep up with the industry and
you chase and okay there's 1900 now
there's 2 000 now there's 2100 and you
have a huge team of people that are like
trying to keep up and tune and optimize
and even when uh one of the big guys
comes out with a new generation of their
chip they have to go back and rewrite
all these things right so really it's
only powered by having hundreds of
people they're all like frantically
trying to keep up and what that does is
that keeps out the little guys
and sometimes the not so little guys the
big guys that are also just not not in
those dominant positions and so
um and so what has been happening and so
a lot of you talk about the rise of new
exotic crazy accelerators people have
been trying to turn this from uh let's
go write lots of special kernels problem
into a compiler problem
and so we and I contributed to this as
well we as initially went into it like
let's go make this compiler problem
phase let's call it and much of the
industry is still in this phase by the
way so it's I won't say this phase is
over and so the idea is to say look okay
what a compiler does is it provides a
much more General extensible
uh hackable interface for dealing with
the general case right and so
um within machine learning algorithms
for example people figured out that hey
if I do a matrix multiplication and I do
a relu right the classic activation
function it is way faster to do one pass
over the data and then do the relu on
the output where I'm writing out the
data because really is just a maximum
operation right Max is zero and so
it's an amazing optimization to take
matmo relu squish together in one
operation now we have Matt morelu
well wait a second if I do that now I
just went from having you know two
operators to three
but now I figure out okay well there's a
lot of activation functions what about
uh leaky rally what about like like a
million things that are out there right
and so as I start fusing these in now I
get permutations of all these algorithms
right and so what the compiler people
said is they said hey cool well I will
go enumerate all the algorithms and I
will enumerate all the pairs and I will
actually generate a kernel for you and I
think that this has been very very
useful for the industry this is one of
the things that powers Google tpus uh
pytorch twos like rolling out really
cool compiler stuff with Triton this
other technology and things like this
and so the compiler people are kind of
coming into their four and saying like
awesome this is a competitive problem
we'll compiler it
here's the problem
not everybody's compiler person I love
compiler people trust me right but not
everybody can or should be a compiler
person it turns out that there are
people that know analog computers really
well or they know some GPU internal
architecture thing really well or they
know some crazy sparse numeric
interesting algorithm that is the cusp
of research but they're not compiler
people and so one of the challenges with
this new wave of Technology trying to
turn everything into a compiler
once again it's excluded a ton of people
and so you look at what does mojo do
what is the modular stack do it brings
programmability back into this world
like it enables I wouldn't say normal
people but like a new you know different
kind of delightful nerd that cares about
numerics or cares about Hardware or
cares about things like this to be able
to express that in the stack and extend
the stack without having to actually go
hack the compiler itself to extend the
stack on the on the algorithm side yeah
and then on the hardware side yeah so
again go back to like the simplest
example of int right and so what both
Swift and Mojo and other things like
this did is we said okay pull magic out
of the compiler and put it in the
standard Library
right so what modular is doing with the
engine that we're providing and like
this this very deep technology stack
right which goes into heterogeneous run
times and like a whole bunch of really
cool really cool things
um this this whole stack allows that
stack to be extended and hacked and
changed by researchers and by Hardware
innovators and by people who know things
that we don't know because you know
modular has some smart people but we
don't have all the smart people it turns
out